it's warmer in here than outside on this
crisp February morning the sweet smell
of ripe strawberries fills the
greenhouse a boo Sammy's family's been
farming this land for generations and 82
years old boo Sammy doesn't only have a
lifetime of farming knowledge but he is
also witnessed the constant change of
this political landscape good non-west
work Mantegna fear is real we used to
sell our product in Israel when we were
under Israeli occupation but since 2006
when Hamas took over and Israeli imposed
the blockade we can't sell in the
Israeli market so farmers income has
decreased a lot now the main market for
Gaza strawberries is the occupied West
Bank around an hour's drive from here
Mifflin telethons will be arrested in
film ear Israeli product compete with us
even in the West Bank because my product
takes days to get there as it has to
follow certain lofty procedures while
Israeli produced takes just a few hours
to reach the market the client prefers
freshly picked rather than mine which
loses 20% of quality along this journey
this abraha certain fertilizers are
banned by Israel citing security reasons
and that too were told is affecting the
quality of the strawberries but despite
that things are moving forward now this
is a relatively new way of growing
strawberries they started hanging them
around three years ago and farmers are
telling us that they get around three
times more strawberries using this
technique rather than just keeping them
in the ground and there's less risk of
disease because they're protected by the
greenhouse and also far from the ground
this hanging method also maximizes the
use of space and it's also pretty while
we're filming a group of visitors arrive
with you I took selfies and videos and I
will upload them to social media I did
not know that we have these forms
they're fantastic and I don't think many
people know about it I think we should
publicize this and increase awareness of
the good things we have but the
restrictions of the blockade are felt in
every layer of this farming process and
there is the neverending cycle of SQL
between Israel and the various armed
groups here well I guess what Margaret
Elena Vietnam the darkest period in our
lives is after 2006 the siege is really
tough and it's meant all our movements
it affects every part of our lives and
unfortunately things are getting worse
you simply cannot predict today what
will happen tomorrow
perhaps a small respite is the reliable
cycle of nature the changing seasons and
the harvest they bring and if you manage
to drown out the constant buzzing of the
Israeli drone in the sky you could just
about imagine a very different reality
Stephanie Decker al Jazeera in the
strawberry fields of Beit Lahiya
northern Gaza